kaka et ludovic chancel
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire
[Musique]
pour toi bonsoir bonsoir alors ludovic
chancel vous êtes le fils de sheila et
vous dit dans le livre que vous publié
chez flammarion quoi que je fasse
quelles que soient mes efforts pour
tenter d'exister par moi même je suis et
je reste le fils de celle à moi qui ne
demandait rien d'autre que d'être celui
d'annie chancelle ça résume bien le
livre when you're voir
ça résume bien le livre ouais ça résume
bien le diable voilà c'est un petit peu
ça c'est difficile d'exister face à
l'énorme chela qui prend énormément
d'importance alors c'est un livre d'une
grande sincérité si parfois même
impudiquement tous les cas très touchant
très très touchant alors on va prendre
les choses par le commencement
[Musique]
alors ça commence le 13 février 1973
dans une église du xiiie arrondissement
quand annie chancel du chellah épouse
guibel votre papa ringo louis l'iccat
deux ans plus tard le 7 avril 1975 vous
naissez ludovic et deux ans plus tard
encore vos parents divorcent ils vont
rester seul avec sheila donc qui va vous
élevez vous dites comme une fleur de
serre c'est à dire complètement coupé du
monde mais oui on vit en vase huis clos
on est en complète autarcie on est on
sait qu'un un clan ouej pas on est sûr
enfin moi je suis sûr protégé
personnellement et assez une vie assez
spéciale 1 c'est un peu comme le jeune
bouddha kaki et protéger tous les
joueurs sort comme ça il aidé et
découvre le monde sur ce nul face à ces
gens là il pleut
et là c'est le drame je suis alors celle
à l'époque est cornaqué par un partout
de carrère elle est absorbée par sa
réussite professionnelle
elle préfère l'amour du public
finalement à votre amour elle travaille
elle travaille dur déjà pour pour nous
enfin pour sa famille pour moi mais si
tu veux c'est difficile à expliquer à un
enfant même si je sais qu'elle travaille
pour moi et pour pour les bienfaits de
la vie enfin pour ça sent quand c'est
dur à expliquer de savoir que sa mère
est adulé par des millions de gens sains
et finalement donne à mon avis à ce
moment là donc il faut se remettre un
peu dans le contexte peu d'importance à
son son garçon finalement c'est ce que
tu penses tu vois aujourd'hui j'ai 30
ans donc je vois autrement mais à
l'époque c'est moi ce que je pense à ce
moment là ouais moi c'est ça il faut se
remettre un petit peu dans le contexte
alors sans doute parce qu elle
culpabilise
elle a beaucoup d'attention pour vous
mais des chansons qui sont too much par
exemple dans un hôtel particulier que
j'habitais à l'époque rue de la fère
mali un jour elle achète un sapin pour
noël qui fait trois étages de haut donc
à elle fait pas grand chose mais quand
elle le fait c'est toujours un peu trop
quoi elles comblent pas mal de choses
elle comble pas mal de choses c'est
normal parce que vous allez souvent
absent donc elle essaie de faire le
maximum quand elle est présente pour que
ce soit facile et d'ailleurs j'en garde
de très bons souvenirs mais c'est vrai
qu'on signifie de pallier le manque est
tout de même malgré toutes les
attentions qu'elle peut avoir
il ya un moment donné où il ya un fossé
qui se creuse je pense que c'est ça
qu'il faut dire alors c'est l'époque de
spacer allait souvent ennuyeux numéro un
par la voilà alors vous quand vous allez
à new york violent concorde a tant qu'à
faire si ouais ouais vous passez pas
vous passer l'été à saint-tropez l'hiver
à méribel enfin vous avez une vie une
vie de rêve d'une vie de jeune prince où
elle c'est une sorte de prison dorée en
fait on s'aperçoit pas tu vois comment
il le monde à l'extérieur et c'est un
petit peu ça c'est alors jusqu'à l'âge
de 12 ans vous ne savez pas ce que fait
votre maire ludovic y vous allez
découvrir ça un jour aussi découvrir les
dommages collatéraux de la célébrité
lorsque gérard de villiers lance cette
horrible affaire celle ait un homme dont
vous seriez un enfant adopté ce qui est
ce qu est ce qui est terrible - c'est
très très dur un point enfin c'est
vraiment un choc mais si tu veux c'est
plus le fait que j'arrive à la maison et
que si tu veux d'une histoire un peu
anodine une bagarre de récréation
[Musique]
j'en parle à ma mère et ma mère tout de
suite se sent blessée ce je pense je
l'expliqué comme ça maintenant mais je
pense le fait de s'expliquer vis-à-vis
de moi le fait que ce soit moi qui lui
en parle le premier elle sait pas
comment gérer une blessure qui pour elle
est restée béante les jusqu'à maintenant
si c'est qu'elle est en fait elle est
pas du tout sereine elle est déçue elle
est maladroite je peux comprendre ça lui
a causé tellement de dommages cela fait
tellement mal est là on a tellement
souffert elles sont tellement elle a
tellement pris plein la gueule parce
qu'on en a pris plein la gueule elle
sait pas comment l'expliquer et comme ça
vient de moi ça prend une proportion une
dimension auquel on peut pas enfin
j'arrive pas à comprendre alors au lieu
de vous calmer à ce moment là elles se
justifient elles vous dis-je une
cassette de ton accouchement que je te
montrerai elle vous la donne cette
cassette où il me la donnes un peu plus
tard me l'a même pas tout de suite à la
zone quant à mon 17e anniversaire
cassette que je n'ai pas regardé je
t'avoue sincèrement il dit mouais
c'est maladroit parce que finalement
elle en devient presque oui c'est
troublant car en fait les gens qui ont
un besoin
se met dans une situation où elle a pas
besoin de se justifier ouais tu vois
pour moi c'est clair ça ma mère voilà en
finale on arrête là la conversation est
elle en train d'amener des preuves alors
que c'est pas la peine en tout cas entre
vous vous en parlez jamais quoi tout ça
non c'est tabou c'est un sujet c'est
tellement alors là vous vivez dans la
maison de feucherolles qui est une
business de villa hollywoodienne dans la
banlieue vers un château disney lien
990 m² habitables séjour de 300 mètres
carrés et puis aussi le musée celle à
vous raconter dans votre livre que
finalement quand elle fait le clip de
bang bang elle garde tout elle garde les
costumes elle garde le décor fasse une
espèce de deux mausolées je pense
qu'elle garde ça pour ça les gens et
c'est un petit peu si tu veux une espèce
de refuge quand elle se sent pas bien
elle a besoin d'avoir tous et des styles
un petit peu du passé elle en a besoin
pour son bien donc je peux comprend
alors vous êtes très beau hein les
cheveux longs ou les yeux vers ses rêves
c'est un garçon c'est clair vous
plaisait beaucoup d'ailleurs vous
plaisait aux filles vous plaisait aux
garçons et en fait c'est l'époque où
vous donnez votre premier baiser un
garçon bah ouais bon c'est petit
libération sexuelle
mais années hippies situe hors là bon
voilà bon jeu plaît aux garçons je
profite pour moi ça n'a jamais été un
tabou mais bon il ya un truc est très
étonnant à votre bouquin c'est que
finalement dès le départ vous à vous et
votre bisexualité sait jamais un
problème pour nous un message à l'air en
tous les cas mais ça jamais atteint pour
passer comme ça les filles aux garçons
sens oui enfin oui
ta blocage accords sectoriels là c'est
sûr non mais c'est vrai que sagem est un
tabou mais bon alors vous découvrez le
sexe cette époque et vous décidez de
quitter le cocon familial
vous dites à votre mère maman je veux
partir à paris il la réaction de votre
mère quel régime je pense maladroitement
parce que je pense que c'est pas le fait
est une maman mais pas son fils dehors
tu vois mais c'est plutôt sous l'emprise
un petit peu se dit écoute très bien il
veut partir il n'y a pas de soucis vous
arrêter à faire voilà ton sac allez je
lui donne trois semaines un mois dans un
mois il revient ouais mais bon j'ai un
caractère on met à la force donc voilà
on en vend roule on là vous avez 17 ans
vous vous retrouvez avec 200 bad en
poche si vous vous dites je lien sans
doute de faire la plus grosse car oui
pour moi c'est horrible bah ouais c'est
une grosse connerie attends je moi je
m'attendais à du soutien je me suis dit
bon c'est pas de souci elle va me
prendre un petit studio il ya pas de
problème ça va me sponsoriser un petit
peu donc y'a pas de soucis mais là je me
retrouve à la porte avec un sac qui pèse
trois tonnes je suis comme ça avec les
cheveux j'ai tous les malheurs du monde
sur moi tout d'un bon c'est vrai que
c'est spécial et jamais à ce moment là
vous avez l'idée de retourner à
feucherolles mais à tanger des couilles
je vais pas revenir j'ai parti je vais
j'avance aussi parce que et puis quelque
part c'est le fait donc plus de pas
vivre dans son nom je me dis ok j'y vais
ouais puis voilà et gm assume et quelque
part c'est important vous commencez
ludovic cette stagiaire chez michel
drucker way pour 200 francs par mois
salut michel voilà votre encore un qui
dit merci à michel drucker absolument
voilà mais rapidement vous plonger dans
le stupre et la luxure bleus le stupre
et la luxure secret
je vais bien compris où ils adduction
mais sinon plus c'est le cas le cuivre
sexe non c'est vrai
mais j'ai 18 ans j'ai envie de jouer et
j'aime m'amuser à tanger 18 ans j'arrive
à paris j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
m'amuser j'ai envie de profiter enfin
chez honda l'a quand même de vous taper
tout ce qui bouge mais à cette époque là
qui s'appelle tout ce qui bouge là même
les couples
bon j'ai des expériences voilà c'est par
proches non il n'ya pas oui je ne vois
pas ça comme un reproche voilà mais bon
vu julie bertin voir les atouts du
libertaire mans je suis pas trop là le
mec vous demande de baisers sa femme
devant lui vous le faites quoi ça normal
c'est pas méchant oui c'est pas nous
c'est ma très méchant ouais c'est pas
méchant
avec demande poliment
tout est bon comme on la baisse ce matin
tu balances pas longtemps s'il vous
plaît il y avait la volonté de pénétrer
dans les bulls battus
donc à l'époque vous êtes complètement
coupé de votre mère vous lui écrivait
une lettre pas de réponse et puis au
bout de six mois elle vous répond la
lettre est tellement pas respectueuse
que vous vous dites mais c'est bien la
peine de me faire attendre mais si tu te
sens là je pense qu'à elle elle est dans
sa démarche où j'ai décidé de partir et
si tu veux elle n'arrive pas à revenir
en arrière elle se dit pas un moment
donné bon allez ça fait quand même allé
moi l'art est quoi ça fait huit mois
donc elle reste sur cette base là bon il
écrit tu vois et comme elle me dit sur
la lettre bon ben voila je pensais pas
que tu aurais dû appeler pourquoi tu as
écrit qu'elle n'aime pas c'est vachement
déstabilisant elle arrive toujours à
renverser le truc et c'est moi qui fuit
mais bon c'est son caractère elle est
comme ça on était meilleurs comme
chanteuse que comme maman encore ma main
je pense qu'être une grande star comme
elle a été une icône c'est ça doit être
difficile mais c'est difficile mais je
suis arrivé très jeune en plus oui donc
elle a pas spécialement peut-être su
s'armer pour [__] messahel madore
comme une maman et qui a un fils unique
elle les fous de son fils il ya pas de
problème mais je pense qu'elle le montre
mal à l'époque vous rencontrez sylvia
jay que la première fille pour qui vous
ressentez vraiment de l'amour et et dans
sa famille beaucoup de chaleur humaine
en fait à ce moment là c'est la famille
de sylvia qu'il ya un petit peu de
familles d'accueil choix sont faites que
pour les gens simples la vie est simple
m'ont aidé à reprendre la tête on a des
maisons
est ce que tu veux de l'argent en fait
on confirme il ya lille a un petit peu
exposées partout même parents divorcés
j'ai une un manque qui est comme aller
avec son caractère et tu t'aperçois que
finalement pour les gens simples n'y a
que l'amour qui contient toujours à
manger sur la table on s'occupe de sa
famille et ça devient tout de suite il
ya plus de poids et c'est ça qui est
important
pour moi c'est de rendre des couleurs
alors vous rencontrez également à
l'époque un dénommé engrais il devient à
votre employeur il a une boutique de
mode aux halles et votre amant ouais
pendant des années ouais ça me julie
boulet samecki l'imsa mais qui parce que
si tu veux en trouvant cette personne je
découvre aussi quelques quelqu'un qui
est important et qui à l'image du papa
dont j'ai besoin donc sam équilibre
énormément quelqu'un qui me fait
confiance quelqu'un qui nous donne la
possibilité d'exprimer dans mon travail
qui nous donne plein de possibilités et
g si tu veux c'est deux piliers de ma
vie vous passer de l'un à l'autre oui -
on peut dire ça comme ça et sylvia c'est
que vous voyez andré andré c'est que
vous voyez sylvia oui on dressait que je
vois sylvia s'il ya des doutes sur rien
mais c'est pas un ménage à trois si tu
veux savoir la création d'un pas du tout
et là vous avez un terrible accident de
scooter
une renault 25 un soir et vous êtes
vraiment détruit fracture ouverte de la
mâchoire les dents exploser la langue
coupée en deux la rate éclatée cette
côte cassée on vit comme à 15 jours f
voilà un orage interne mais rate
absolument quinze jours de coma un mois
et demi deux mois à l'hôpital et simon 6
8 mois de rééducation intensive la
remontée sera longue ouais ça a été dur
ça a été vraiment un passage assez
difficile ouais ça c'est dur c'est assez
dur parce que tu sors de l'hôpital je
faisais 55 kg à peu près alors j'en fais
75 d'habitude c'est un peu difficile sur
quand tu te vois dans la glace tu vois
un fantôme et de zombies bon qui il faut
merci
et il faut il pour moi merci c'est
gentil et il faut et tu vois il faut il
faut remonter t'as pas le choix donc on
te dit en plus que t'es pas sûr de
retrouver 100% de ses capacités donc
finalement tu dis bah je vais pas je
vais parler d' assange arrivait à 130
histoire de m'emmerder tout le monde
donc c'est à vous raconter la
convalescence à feucherolles les
vacances au aux caraïbes avec sylvia et
votre maman et là vous décidez de faire
connaissance avec votre père qui habite
à toulouse il est parti lorsque j'avais
deux ans j'ai dû le voir je sais pas une
fois je m'en rappelle plus quand j'avais
six ans j'ai par un grand souvenir et
puis je les ai eu deux trois fois au
téléphone et c'est tout donc j'ai pas eu
de son de cloche à côté donc je veux
avoir si tu veux ma propre opinion sur
bas sur le bonhomme quoi alors ce sera
jamais un père mais je me suis peut-être
que je peux trouver un dj allez vous
arrivez dans une cité pavillonnaire un
peu un peu défraîchi à tous un peu
années 60 voyez une vieille dame qui
veut dire que votre grand mère et qu'il
appelle et la voyais arriver un mec on
shore temps marcel en tongs qui vous dit
qu'est ce que tu fous là toi ouest et
maxime dit mu me dis [__] tu
ressembles à ta mère
t'aiment pourquoi tu es venu suis même
pas sûr que tu sois mon fils j'ai rien à
me dire voilà quand je vois je vois ta
mère
tu fais là ouais bon ok bon bah écoute
ça a duré allégé pas une minute et demie
mais quand vous lui dites je crois que
je vais y aller
est situé ya des photos un peu dans le
pavillon puis jeudi mais quand même tu
voyais qu'elle quelques photos de moi
donc ah non mais je suis pas chez moi
ici
ouais bon ben je sors je fais dit m et
si tu veux comme je suis pas du tout à
100% à cette époque là je pleure au bout
de dix mètres mais comme un bébé mais
finalement en pleurant espèce de poids
qui s'en va comme ça et je m'aperçois
que finalement les liens du sang malgré
ce qu'on peut dire bon ben voila je suis
tombé sur un mec bas c'est mon géniteur
il s'appelle dit
on peut dire il s'appelle we l'iccat et
exprès en fait ce que vous dites ce
qu'il a jamais vraiment aimé votre mère
ah non non ouais ouais pour moi voilà
c'est ça c'était plus un coup de pub
bourdon dont elle qui est vraiment été
meurtri par sa parce qu'elle était elle
a voulu un enfant avec une amoureuse de
lui bah oui je pense qu'elle s'est
mariée elle a voulu avoir un assez bon
et des photos dans télé 7 jours et un
papier sur lui dans télé c'est sûr il ya
des photos il est assez beau le par
rapport à moi il n'est plus bon
maintenant à ses jours provoque lui par
des gens
non c'est vrai que c'est gentil ça va
voilà alors là vous marier pour faire
plaisir à sylvia en fait au départ n'est
pas vraiment envie de vous marier et
quand elle vous le propose je faisais
pas dire non quoi
si tu veux je me rende un petit peu le
contexte de l'époque moi j'ai voulu me
marier à 20 ans 22 ans j'ai toujours eu
des non non j'arrive à un âge où j'ai 25
ans ou dont je sors de plein d'histoires
j'ai pas vraiment la tête à marier mais
je suis dans un clan elle a toujours été
là pour moi donc j'ai envie de lui faire
partager ce bonheur j'ai envie qu'elle
soit dans le clan chance et j'ai envie
de faire plaisir à mes grands-parents
gens soient fiers de moi et donc je me
dis allez pourquoi pas en avant à
l'ombre et
à l'église ce qui est terrible c'est que
en enterrant petit garçon vous tombez
sur une nathalie dont vous faites la
connaissance dans les toilettes on peut
dire ouais et c7 nathalie 7 nathalie je
résume vite les choses mais tu résumes
vite les choses mais dans le bouquin
ouais et 7 nathalie non ce qui est
terrible c'est que cette nathalie il
vous la reverrai après une pomme ou
serait marié lavabo et elle vivra et
elle vous fera un enfant dans le dos
ouais
ouais bon donc on se voit un petit peu
puis très vite je me dis vous attends je
suis content viens de me marier je n'ai
pas commencé à voir une relation extra
conjugale c'est vraiment suffit donc je
mets fins et rapidement et au bout d'un
an et demi j'ai la mer donc là nathalie
qui m'appellent et qui me dit bah écoute
et félicitations ma fille vient
d'accoucher très belle petite fille je
suis pas ravi pour elle et vous êtes le
papa plus tarder on
est donc là j'ai mon monde touchera une
carte qui fait la claque l'aqlpa veut
dire que le mariage n'arrange rien vous
dit en parlant de sylvia ce mariage a
tué notre amour ça arrive sur beaucoup
de mariages je suis pas il n'y a pas que
moi je suis pas le seul exemple mais ça
arrive de se marier et puis sur ces
connu assez jeune donc il ya un an
donnez nous nos routes se séparent
pascal à d'autres envies que moi j'ai
peut-être d'autres envies aussi et puis
voilà ça nous empêche pas qu on s'est
énormément aimé qu'on a vécu une très
belle histoire d'amour là c'est le début
ludovic de votre descente aux enfers
beaucoup de cocaïne
beaucoup ces petits aussi jusqu'à 20
grammes par semaine c'est beaucoup quand
même nom mais 20 g c'était minimiser les
guettent
je pense que 20 grammes c'est minimum
n'arrive d'ailleurs de faire des 72
heures avec 40 g 1 aimer c'est au total
destruction comme j'explique dans l'île
via un passage où si tu veux sylvia
sylvia sang rare parce que je lui dis
tout je dis toute la vérité et puis donc
j'ai pas les atouts à la pâte
rochechouart elle s'en va et je ferme
toutes les portes de 10h arrive je paye
par ilm il m'apporte un sachet oui je
rappelle 35 40 g et si tu veux là je
m'enferme j'arrache le téléphone je
commence à mutiler ouais c'est totale
destruction ces jeux j'assume pas du
tout le fait que je suis un jeune mère
devant vous ne savez pas du tout à ce
moment là non je suis pas prêt du tout
je je déteste je veux le détruire le but
c'est totale destruction je veux
m'anéantir il ya un drogué puis à le
sexe si ce que vous appelez vos nuits
fauves en fait tous les boîtes
échangistes les bacs ou momo le bois de
boulogne la totale coin la prostitution
tu peux le dire ainsi
mais c'est pour le fait de ne pas se
regarder dans la glace moi un moment
donné je me dis je vais y passer parce
que vu les quantités de drogue que je
prenais pas le courage si tu veux te
faire la démarche d'aller acheter un
emprunt il me met une balle dans la tête
sur têt était plus un mais j'y arrive
pas j'ai pas sa démarche jamais avec les
quantités que je prends je me dis à un
moment donné je vais partir et pour me
salir encore plus au temps de détruire
au maximum et c'est le but voilà
maintenant je sais pas si c'est bien ou
pas bien ce que j'ai vraiment voulu
enfin ça va sortir du bouquin c'est les
30 dernières pages c'est vraiment cette
descente aux enfers vivre une vraie
descente aux enfers tu vois c'est pas
ouais je prends un peu de drogue où je
sors un petit peu on sait pas ce que je
fais non voilà voilà ce que j'ai fait
voilà maintenant ou bien ou pas bien
c'est pas la question mais c'est une
vraie descente et c'est ce que je veux
expliquer dans votre seule ambition à ce
moment là c'est de vous salir de vous à
vivre
vous pourrez dans la glace je veux voir
un cadavre c'est le but mais j'y arrive
très bien vous allez vous allez à un
moment dans des boîtes sont deux sexes
et vous vous laisser posséder par tour
mais voilà j'ai envie de vendre mon âme
vendre mon corps pense que je suis
vivante ce que je représente vendre
c'est à dire le salir chose de tout le
che pas l'honnêteté toute la la pudeur
que j'ai envie de lajemmerais j'ai envie
j'ai envie de la détruire c'est dur
c'est sait que c'est sa a procédé
difficile de se dire à un moment donné
quand toi tu décides de te faire du mal
il ya plus de limites si tu veux citer
un adversaire vous battez si le choc et
du vent il ya un moment donné où tu te
mets en retrait parce que dis je veux
pas trop l'animé là que c'est dans la
démarche que toi tu as envie de te salir
il ya plus de limite et c'est ce que je
voulais l'adversaire est dans ta tête
par un moment vous commencez à choisir
vos clients sur internet parce que vous
découvrez que c'est plus facile
finalement que la porte dauphine et là
vous tapez ce cas-ci clients par jour
quoi
dans un appartement qui sait que
l'appartement c'est vrai que c'est un
appartement c'est un dépôt temps un
dépotoir bon c'est un passage j'essaie
de l'expliquer jeu j'espère que ça
choquera pas trop trop de gens j'essaie
au moins tout cas elle expliqué avec mes
mots et je fais assez sincère oui c'est
sans service est touchant c'est gentil
si vous priez aussi mais de rentrer dans
le détail à ce point et de nous raconter
comme ça
ignorant merci mais j'ai en tout cas si
nous donne essentielle fils de
guinée chez flammarion
et là comment ça va
vous aimez mieux maintenant ça commence
à venir